[Music]  the National Hockey League's labor  lockout is into its 80th day eighty days  yeah ladies and gentleman though there  is a silver lining okay it turns out a  member of the Stanley Cup champion LA  Kings forward Dustin Penner is a big fan  of our show he's such a fan such a fan  he has volunteered to intern here at  Conan during his work stoppage he said  he'd help out and that's just what we  let him do and I think he's doing a  great job so far I almost done yeah I'm  almost done  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  Dustin I'm told Dustin has my coffee  right now Dustin you're an  just leave it I can bring it up there  you'd have to bring it over there just  leave it right there on Annie's podium  now you just wear right there  thanks Dustin okay  [Applause]